I mean I don't think anyone's doing
anything with the kung-fu property right
now so let's see what somebody does with
the knockoff so announcement that while
not announcement but breaking news that
I found kind of surprising deadline who
has a pretty solid track record on their
on their breaking news panning out
they're usually pretty good at labeling
something unsubstantiated if it is that
Disney or Marvel is going to be doing a
movie for shang-chi the master of kungfu
I like the the article says that it's
going to be a movie and they say a
tentpole which to me says like in
theaters that was surprising because
when I when I saw the name shang-chi I
thought oh I bet they'll do the I bet
they're doing a streaming show or you're
streaming miniseries or a streaming film
even and it's like it's implying that
it's gonna be in theaters I mean really
but it made a connection that has it
make more sense but if this is the
thinking I think it might bite them in
the butt so what the deadline article
references is it makes the connection to
Black Panther which was obviously huge
and Black Panther was you know the first
black superhero of the current sort of
cycle of superheroes not the first black
superhero in movies ever but first one
of like the cinematic universe era in a
film directed by a black man focusing on
black characters set in Africa like if
it really embraced all that and they
yielded huge dividends and was a very
good movie in addition to all that so
the idea seems to now be that they are
going to try and do something similar to
that with an A
character change he is Chinese hmm I
should have checked that I actually
don't know cuz I don't know the
character that well like my enjoy
martial arts stuff every now and then
but martial arts comics like never been
my bag really but you know they're
looking at at Asian directors and and
and all of that and they've got somebody
working a script guy who wrote The
Expendables I believe working on the
script and if the idea is that they're
hoping to do for Asian audiences what
black panther did for black audiences ah
hey don't I think they're they are gonna
be sorely disappointed I think they all
I think the the tell-tale sign of this
will be how much money they spend
because if they spend as much on this as
they spend making black panther yeah
they're gonna get real disappointed by
that by the returns on this if they
could if they keep it as a controlled
budget which honestly I think you could
with this character he's like he's
perfect for a fighting tournament style
story which you can do relatively
cheaply but the reason that I say it
might bite them in the butt if they're
hoping to replicate what happened with
black panther is that there isn't the
same hole in the market that there was
for black panther now you know black
patent because black panther wasn't just
the first black superhero of the current
cycle of superhero filmmaking it also
went in hard on looking at Africa at
African characters at African culture
and while you could say there's a ton of
superhero movies movies that did that
and like embrace this aesthetic the
whole life or a future or something not
much there wasn't much there really
nothing at a high budget so there was
just a hole in the market that Disney
found that Disney and Marvel found and
they filled with again I feel a very
good movie shanky by comparison where we
don't exactly
I have an aching absence of kung-fu
films again you could make the argument
like there hasn't been like a really
good big-budget kung-fu movie in a long
time I'm lightly sure what the last one
might be but it's it's not as much of a
there's a need and something that they
could get in on with this that there was
with black panther because you know
martial arts films have never really
gone away as much as the sort of trend
that Schanke was created to profit off
of the UM back when he's created in the
70s I think you know that very it waned
but it never went away and I'm not like
for my understanding and the folks that
I know who like kung fu movies I don't
think throwing more money at it is gonna
automatically pull them in so I think
whether or not this works again depends
on how much I'd like it could be
comparable to black been there insofar
as it allows Marvel Marvel to sort of
have another milestone in its cap in
terms of you know getting to an Asian
lead character first for this cycle of
superheroes which you know that's not a
bad thing but if they're expecting the
level of cultural fun and then if they
do if they make a good movie again
assuming they make a good movie and not
an embarrassment then it will poor
there's a good chance of it being
embraced by an by an audience that feels
like it hasn't gotten a character made
specifically for them yet but again
because of the genre that shang-chi
takes place in it's just it's just not
as much of a void it's not as much of a
vacuum that's just waiting to be filled
as Black Panther was I mean because
Black Panther is equal parts superhero
and Game of Thrones
and you know that like I said the really
unique aesthetic get brought to it and I
just don't think shang-chi has as much
uniqueness to offer in it you know
beyond just offering a superhero to a
demographic that hasn't had one in this
current cycle of films sort of setting
aside the business end of it and the
Returns end of it like I said for my
money I think a tournament would be a
really good thing to do like I what I
don't want them to do sort of again
setting aside the business end and the
the demographics of the box office and
all that what I don't want them to do is
to turn shang-chi into a generic
superhero keep him as he is have him be
the kung-fu master have him exist in
that world use a genre that is different
from the other stuff because that's
usually been the best or at least most
entertaining and interesting Marvel
films of the later end of things because
as much as I might I might like dr.
things it is ultimately another
superhero origin whereas I can look at
something like on Captain America Winter
Soldier and go that's an espionage
thriller and I can look at something
like well I was gonna say guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 I don't even know how
to classify that one but it's
practically a family drama or you know
ant-man it's a heist film so there's all
these you know when they sort of drill
into the uniqueness of a character not
just the gimmicks but what genre it
could allow them to explore I really
want them to dig into that more because
at this point their state their stable
of characters the big ones are always
going to be safe bets they are always
gonna have you know the Wow I say always
eventually the actors will start will
stop playing Thor Captain America Iron
Man whatever but like they've got plenty
of just superhero movies let's really
start exploring some of those genres
that Marvel Comics can and have touched
on that will give a different feel to it
and
force it into a superhero structure I
think that's gonna be their best bet but
then again as I said kung-fu movies as a
genre are much more well-trodden ground
than what they were able to do with
black panther so even if they go in that
direction and do the Marvel version of a
kung fu tournament movie which I would
still like to see I don't think they
need they should be expecting black
panther level interest in that because
you know we've got kung fu movies but
yeah I don't know I'll see I'll be
keeping an eye on this one
shang-chi the master of kungfu get
enough film what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff that
you can do because there's buttons that
there's links including one to my
patreon if you're feeling generous if
not don't worry about it other links you
can check out don't want to click on
those that's fine too because at the end
of the day you are the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]